o latitude pessoal daqui quem falou dar
que sejam muito bem vindos é mais de um
vídeo e o estrago de que uma coisa que
você já não tenho pedido muito nestes
últimos dois dias que é dar que faz um
vídeo a reagir ao trailer do fight night
at freddy's 3
eu não sei até que ponto isso pode ser
interessante vocês virem a minha reação
mas o que é facto é que vocês me pedem
muito isso no facebook no twitter não
sei o que se passa mas o trailer deve
ter alguma coisa de especial alguns usos
não sai mas se você espere muito para eu
fazer por isso como eu ainda não vi o
trailer eu vou fazer agora um vídeo que
mostrava que a minha reação e tal que eu
possa estar em dia não é mais gente diz
pessoal eu quero denunciar uma live
streaming no dia 31 sábado já esta
semana uma web stream uma mega live
stream praia de quatro a cinco horas
depois vai definir sete fredes não o 3
porque ainda não sei o jogo não é eu vou
juntar alguns jogos foi mais do fight
night at freddy's house nessa live com
vocês
vou também oferecer uma equipe do fight
night at freddy's 2 por isso fiquem
atentos fosse jogos também vai ter
convidado em princípio vou falar de
teorias coisas acerca do gene matronic
tudo e mais alguma coisa vou fazer nessa
live com vocês não percam vai ser mesmo
do rádio macau não é e agora vamos lá
ver o trailer do fight night at freddy's
3 que deve ter alguma coisa ali por trás
porque senão vocês não teriam tanto deve
ter para alguns está alguma coisa sem
torcida não sai mas vamos lá então vir
vou quebrar o meu internet explorer
google não usa o google chrome o firefox
um dos caras que explora a gente não
quer só para lá então fui inscrito 3211
lei o que vai acontecer
o que estamos dentro da pizzaria parece
estar de frente mais velho talvez acho
eu para perceber as palavras né
ok grill cambé que nós vamos voltar é
porque não consegue inglês né
jogava ali alguma coisa buscar na
pizzaria o que se passava ali dentro do
meu cérebro além do super ansioso por
este jogo é o boni
os reflexos e pinta que já mas parecem
normais
só assim entra joão mas ficou aquém do
que está querendo tudo o que faz é
fredes 3 é que está mesmo em ok
espera se que até o próximo vídeo
conclusões que o tiro este trailer é
pizzaria por ser mais velha por isso
deve ser tipo uns anos mais à frente a
alguma coisa assim possível é que eu não
consegui perceber se o rooney será o
fred estava ali tipo amarelo tudo
destruído resgatar michel temer uma
porca e não sei mas acho que torcia o o
ônibus tinha as orelhas de coelho eu não
sei se eles vão dar alguma coisa ou não
se nós vamos conseguir encher o evento
assuntos ficar dentro da sala a mesma e
não faz idéia é mais do que eu tenho
certeza que eu vou fazer uma série de
sinais é fredes três podem contar com
isso espero também que seja mais justo
do que o do gil que um juiz não é
obviamente tem que tá mais justa dormiu
com bonilha que usou um freeroll que
aquilo era também está mais justo a dor
mas é e só espero que vocês tenham
gostado de ver aqui o trailer comigo eu
não sei por que vocês me pedirem tanto
né isso já sabem contem com live stream
no sábado dia 31 desta semana não se
esqueçam pessoal
deixem eu posso apoio fiquem bem e até a
próxima